[Music]
single parents we don't volunteer we
just try and survive until a time in the
day when it's appropriate to open wine
late Meester plays a single mom on her
new ABC sitcom single parents has being
on this show gotten you prepared for
what your thought in your future my kid
is three not seven so like the school
drop offs have just sort of started that
but in real life she and husband Adam
Brody are raising their three-year-old
daughter
Arlo how do you and Adam split up your
parenting duties do you have like
certain tasks that you do and he does um
I think we're a pretty modern couple I
think we sort of toggle back and forth
we both sort of we both work but also
being actors like I think we understand
what each other were both going through
and I also think the nice thing about
being an actor is that you can work a
lot and when work is work it's a super
intense and long hours and you might not
see your family for a long period but
then you know I'll have like months off
at a time so I can really like be home
and spend time so I prefer it that way
you think Layton would be singing that
tune at home with little Arlo but she
told e.t Arlo is actually into more
unconventional choices she's written
into Edward Scissorhands it's actually a
bit not like really violent or anything
it's like very sweet and this is yeah
because we were like I don't want to
watch these cartoons and watch like
better movie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]